Our production designer and his team
have done such a fantastic job of
not only creating cool environments,
but sticking to this idea
that I think is so central
to the show of functionality.
When I met Matt and Ben, I felt like
we had a connection right away.
I was attracted to this show
for all of the possibilities
of where we had been
and where we were going to go.
In the writers room,
we’re throwing things out and we're like,
“Well, what if there's the surface
level of the base?
But then there's an underground level,
and what if there's
an asteroid hunting ship?
But then there's also
other types of ships and rovers?”
and Seth was able to give us like 95%
of what we came up with,
which is insane.
Let’s just hope this doesn't get to his head.
I'm surprised it still fits in his helmet.
Both on the moon and even on Mars,
shapes will not be square.
They'll be round or oval
because of the difference between
inside pressure and outside pressure.
One of the big things
we keep coming up against
is that building a lot of structures
on the surface
makes no sense
because of the radiation risk.
That was a really exciting idea.
Like, what does that mean
to go underground
and how do you make
the world underground feel different?
We used references from naval vessels.
You walk down a hallway,
and you feel like you're at the bottom
of a battleship.
Astronauts and cosmonauts, scientists
and pilots, they all work together.
But us down here,
at the end of the day,
we are just the help.
The barrel-vaulted spaces
like the commissary or
the greenhouse are an incredible
look because it's translucent.
You can see that
there's orange light coming in.
The most beautiful thing
I have ever seen.
In the United States,
of course, we ended Season 3
with everything getting blown up.
Mission Control was destroyed
to the point that it needed
to be rebuilt
within the same existing shell.
So now it has a whole new look.
It's got new consoles, new lighting.
Everything's been redone.
The colors, the finishes.
Today, we embrace the 21st century,
the beginning of a new era.
We have a whole side of our story
that's in the Soviet Union.
I was fortunate to be part of a scout
to two countries,
Bulgaria and to Lithuania, where we were able
to gather a lot of research.
It highlighted for me
the differences stylistically
that's so different between here and there.
The work we will do together
will take us far into the cosmos.
I could never have done this project
without the support that I've had.
The cinematographers,
the visual effects people, everybody.
It's an incredible collaboration.
None of it would have been possible
without all of you.